Library of Congress
Drawn to Purpose
>> Can you hear me in the back
of the room?
All right.
There's still a few folks
trickling in.  I hope everyone
has had the opportunity to enjoy
the preview of the illustrations
on the PowerPoint loops.  What
do you think?  It blows you
away, right?
From the 1800s to the present
day, all kinds of topics, very
exciting.
I'd like to welcome you to the
Library of Congress this
afternoon on auspicious day in
March.
I'm Helena, director of
collections and prince in chief
of the photographs division.
I have a stake in the
proceedings today cheering
Martha on.  The prints and
photographs division is home to
a rapidly growing of work by
women artists.
We are very grateful to the
Carolyn and Erwin Swan
Foundation, which supported
these new acquisitions and also
sponsoring today's event.
Our program features a
conversation with three
acclaimed women artists.  How
about that?
Have you been called "acclaimed"
before?  I'm hoping.
We are celebrating both Women's
History
Month and the brand-new
publication
called "drawn To Purpose" by
colleague
Martha Kennedy, your moderator
today, curator of applied
graphic arts.
The opening slide show loop gave
you a glimpse of the art created
by women now represented all of
it in the Library's
collection from vibrant drawings
by our panelists back into the
1800s.
Often we think women whose names
you
may never have heard of, but
well worth becoming acquainted.
Because the range of topics that
women address and explore has
broadened
greatly across this last 150
years, a big point in the book,
to watch how women and art have
been able to interact
and be published, be known to
the world far more publicly.
The fact that work by so many
women has
been overlooked and
under-recognized was the very
thing that motivated Martha
Kennedy to dive deep into
research,
starting almost a decade ago.
She wrote the book, Drawn to
Purpose with terrific support
from publishing office well
represented today, and also
prepared the companion
exhibition currently on view in
the graphic arts gallery.  And
I'll take a moment to mention
that we hope you'll have time to
visit the show after the panel
presentations, and it is
conveniently located next to the
gift shop where you'll all be
able to acquire your very own
copy of Drawn to Purpose signed
by the author.
I was told what a special
privilege it has been to
undertake these dual projects,
that celebrate women's
remarkable contributions to both
art forms, illustration and
cartoon.
She wants to thank her many
colleagues across the library
who have supported and helped
her complete this work.
It is now my honor to introduce
our speakers.  Barbara
Brandon-Croft, would you mind
just standing briefly so we can
all...
[Applause]
Barbara created the
groundbreaking comic "where I'm
coming from" which ran from
fifteen years 1990 to 2005.  The
first African American woman to
have a nationally syndicated
strip, she introduced an
engaging cast of black women
whose conversations brought
topical themes into the comics.
Historical and contemporary race
and gender issues.
She has also published two
well-received comic collections
and continues using artistic
talent by illustrating
publications that promote
activism.
These include a guide for black
teen
girls and recent anthology
called APB, artists against
police brutality.
Whitney Sherman -- we're moving
alphabetically.
[Applause]
Whitney is director of the MFA
illustration practice program at
the Maryland institute college
of art in Baltimore, Maryland.
As a multi-facetted
award-winning illustrated she
created artwork for national
magazines, corporations and book
projects, some featuring
narrative content, others
focused on aspects of
illustration itself.
Whitney recently co-authored and
edited a monumental new book.
Listen to this topic.  History
of illustration.
Sweeping, covering the range of
image making and print history
from around the world spanning
ancient to modern times.  We owe
you a debt there, I think.
Jillian Tamaki.
[Applause]
In a short span of years,
Jillian has produced an
impressive volume and variety of
work that includes two
award-winning graphic novels in
collaboration with cousin Mariko
a short story collection,
award-winning web
congresswoman milk and
illustrations for newspapers and
magazines, book covers
and her first children's book,
"They Say Blue."
Authors grace The New York Times
book review include a wonderful
portrait of Librarian of
Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden, so
we're particularly grateful in
that area too.
Unfortunately, Dr. Hayden is not
able to join us today.  She
sends her regrets.
This is one of her favorite
topics,
books and illustrations, but
she's been called away.  Martha
Kennedy is stepping in as the
panel moderator and Dr. Hayden's
message to the foreward of the
book is what I have been asked
to read to you to represent her.
Dr.
Hayden recalled being a kid who
read everything, and personally
I believe her.
She poured over the
illustrations just as much as
the accompanying words.  That's
the key part.
She wrote, in the foreward, "
Images
make reading more meaningful and
more memorable."
I think at this point I'm going
to say take it away, Martha.
Please come to the stage and
we'll help you get to the
graphic arts gallery at the end
of the program.
Thank you.
>> MARTHA: Thank you all so much
for being here.  Can you hear
me?
Sort of?
Okay.  Okay, great.
Thanks so much.
And thank you Helena for your
opening remarks and
introduction.
I would also like to take this
moment to express my thanks to
my colleagues
across the library who have
helped and
supported me in completing these
wonderful projects.
I feel so privileged to have
worked on
the book and the exhibits Drawn
to Purpose.
Turning to our panelists, it is
an honor
and privilege for me to moderate
today's conversation.
We look forward to hearing your
perspectives and your insights
into the arts of illustration
and cartooning.
As wonderful creators in these
art forms.
I would like to begin by asking
each of
you, what is it like to be an
illustrator and/or a cartoonist
today?  Do you think the playing
field is equal?
Who would like to start?
>> With the new administration,
we have women here.
No,, we're not equal, and a long
time when we really aren't.
I think about how women are
born, we come here and only to
find out as we get
older that we're considered
lesser, you
know, our points of view aren't
-- we
start to understand that our
points of
view aren't taken as seriously
for...
>> MARTHA: Can you hear?
>> Holy moly. Hello? Can you
hear me?
Okay.  Sorry.
My point is that women are born
and we come here and then we
start to find out
that we are considered lesser,
and we're not taken as
seriously.  The older you get,
the more you find out, it's --
as a kid, you know, the boys are
like suddenly like, no, we're
going to play football, but you
can be the cheerleader.  What!?
you know, you're ready to play.
And you fainted out if you want
to be -- you find out if you
want to be heard, your point of
view to be heard, you have
to make yourself heard and you
have to
be loud and nobody likes a loud
woman, it seems.
So there's a lot of -- you come
to
that realization, and honestly,
being a black woman, you're less
than lesser,
you know, you're like least, you
know, you're not only not heard
or you could
be ignored, you could be a
suspect, you know, there's still
many things that happen.
So the playing field isn't
level.  I don't know when that
is going to happen.
>> MARTHA: Okay.
>> Hello, can you hear me?
I'll hold this in case.
So illustration does not -- it
does not exist in a vacuum.
It's a part of society, and to
sort of answer why women are
de-valued in society is like a
whole other round table, I
think, but, yeah, I feel like
it's very complicated,
illustration, for
me, the way I conducted my
career has been very linked to
the industry of illustration and
mainstream publishing,
and the publishing industry, and
that can be really complicated.
Especially when I'm working in
-- I
work in comics, which is
famously a very male-dominated
little niche of drawing, but
then now I'm in picture -- doing
stuff with picture books, where
that industry is, you know, 90%
female in terms of the creators
and the gate keepers and the
book sellers and librarians and
parents buying the books
and all this stuff, yet still
the issues persist with who gets
the awards and who gets the
acclaim and money and all these
things that trickle down.
So it's like it's even more
complicated than it seems on the
space sometimes, but, yeah, I
think identity
has become a very big part of
publishing
and culture at large now and so
it's an evolving thing.
I feel strange -- I can feel --
I actually don't do a lot of
women in
comics and women in
blankety-blank panels, because I
feel that it's uttering, you
know, it can feel like we
talk about we're okay with this
stuff as this sort of, like,
separate thing, or it's safe to
analyze it within this
closed sealed-off context, but I
always want to -- until the day
comes where I'm
looking forward to when it
becomes more integrated and we
don't have to have special days
and that would seem weird
because we're integrated on a
more daily level.
>> MARTHA: Thank you. Very
thoughtful.
>> Pass the baton.
A lot of what I wanted to say
has already been said, but I
wanted to really start, if I had
been the first person to speak,
I would have said I was so glad
that you didn't say, is there a
level playing field for women
illustrators.  Because I think
when we continue to label us as
women illustrators, rather than
illustrators, we already create
a division there.
We create a separate category
that is problematic, and it
becomes something hard.
It's not that we're not women,
but we have to crawl out of this
hole that has been developed by
ost sizing that, by
labeling it that way, like an
asterisk.
And what is really curious, too,
is as an educator, I've been
teaching part-time and full-time
for almost 30
years and the majority of my
students are women.
So when I look out into the
world, I
see more men that are out there
that are nameable, that become
the names in the industry, and I
think a lot of it does
come out of not having people
that are women that are
illustrators but by having art
directors or judges on panels or
whatever, those are the ar
bitters of
who is going to become a name or
whose work is going to be seen
in a publication or in an
annual.  So because of that I
think that has to shift a little
bit.  I think there is more of
an awareness of that now.
I think people are being
sensitive, maybe we have to go
through this period
of identifying women and talking
about women for -- I mean,
they're only -- it's like half
the planet, right?  I don't know
why it's been so invisible, but
maybe we have to go through this
little phase in order for us to
not have to do it this way.
>> These are just very
thoughtful answers.
Would you be willing to say that
there's been some progress in
the last
20 years at all in certain areas
for women?
>> WHITNEY: I would. I would
say there's some progress.  We
can look at things like the
director of the society of
illustrators is a woman.
The majority of the presidents
of the illustration conference,
which is the only conference
that is national that is for
illustration, the majority of
the presidents have been women.
So there are people that are in
leadership roles that in these
things that are -- it's
contemporary.
It's in the last 15, maybe even
10 years that it's different.
So there are role models for
women that are coming up that
can look at that
and say, well, that's possible
to do.
>> MARTHA: Yeah, there are a
few.
>> WHITNEY: There are other
precedents to be a woman.
>> MARTHA: That's interesting.
We have the art editor of The
New Yorker is a woman and
cartoon editor.
So there are some -- a few
encouraging signs.
>> I mostly travel independent,
but
when I started 15 years ago, it
was just like so different in
terms of -- well,
now it's like the market for,
like, YA
comics and kid comics and stuff
like that has burst forward and
I think the
most prominent people doing that
are --
like Randy feltmeyer is the apex
of all of that, and loved by
girls and boys, and that's
encouraging, of course, and then
you have other issues how
identity
becomes a marketable thing and
all these other things, but that
has changed so
much since I started.
>> MARTHA: And look at the
comics pages
in newspapers and it's better
online.
>> I mean, for me, you know, so
many years ago, to be the first
black woman in the mainstream
press in the newspapers, that
was big.  But also by me being
the first black woman in the
mainstream press in newspapers,
I was the only one, and I
was kind of -- you think you're
breaking the door down, so more
can come in, but you're really
clogging the door, you know,
because you're there.
And it's like, okay, hold on to
this...
[ Laughter ]
>> But I haven't done it since
2005,
and there has not been somebody
who has
recognized a black woman
cartoonist for the newspaper.
The newspapers are dying,
clearly, but it's true.
So it's hard for me in my
specific area of doing this to
see progress.  So that's a
downer.
>> I think that as a result,
like web comics have been so
embraced by women because
there's -- you can just skip
directly to your audience,
right?
And I think that that's now, if
you go
to the Expo here outside of --
in Bethesda, Maryland, you see
that gradually change, like more
women and they build their
audience -- clearly there is an
appetite for it, and for
racialized women as well.
And so you don't have to
necessarily go through these
mainstream channels to, like,
get your work out, and then
there's a reverse thing of,
like, now the mainstream wants
that thing.
It's like a turn-around.
>> MARTHA: Great. Good point.
And this leads me to another
question.
Could you comment on the impact
of social media on work in both
fields?
What do you think about that?
>> I think about --
>> Positive and negative.
>> Me?
>> Yes, all three of you. I
would love to hear what...
>> You know, social media is a
strange bird.
And I am older, so it's even
stranger to me, because it's
new.  So it's not all good, but
there are some good points.
It does help create communities
that
are supportive, you know, you
can -- I can -- every once in a
while I can feel compelled to do
a strip and I can put it on my
Facebook page.  I actually have
one.
And I can get such a positive
response.
Like, do it again, Barbara! We
need to hear these girls.  Let's
hear these black women talk.
And it's just very encouraging.
So while it is a weird kind of
thing, it does create certain
communities, and
it does help bring like-minded
people together to make points.
Even if we're just patting each
other on our backs, you know, it
kind of feels good.  It's a
community.
>> Well, I was going to say
that most illustrators -- I
can't speak for cartoonists, but
I imagine it's very similar, we
work by ourselves.  So unless
you're going out and teaching
and getting yourself exposed to
people in a work situations, the
mar jort of your time you spend
by yourself, and so social media
adds a layer of connectivity
that is really helpful.
You get to see what other people
are doing or tell them what you
think about what they're doing.
The other side of it, too, is
that there
have been quite a few places
where women
have gotten beaten up in social
media,
and other places where they can
find refuge.  There are some
private Facebook groups where
people can -- women can talk
about what is happening with
them.  They can talk about
whether they think
they're getting paid less or
whether somebody is bullying
them or other, you know, topics
that are distressful and you
need to find support somewhere.
So it's like everything, it's
got otwo sides.
>> I think that social media
has brought a lot of different
kinds of people to illustration
and comics, and
it was very, very much needed,
because
it is -- I feel like when I
started, very predominantly
white male and straight and,
like, now I feel like it's
really expanded.
And I used to -- when I started,
I really linked illustration
with this commercial aspect.
It's like, you're not an artist,
you're working with a client,
you know what I mean?  And
you're creating a product.
And now I feel like I can't -- I
feel it's a much more nebulous
thing that actually because it's
brought in all these different
people, really question some of
the power structures around it
and, like, how it moves and
they're not necessarily -- they
think about it in a
really, really different way,
and it's -- but it can be really
scary, some of
this stuff with the being a
woman on the Internet is like
just kind of a scary place
sometimes.  But I can't imagine
my career without it.  I
graduated in 2003, like right at
the start of it, and I just
don't think I
would be where I am without
continually
sharing online and you're never
supposed
to say that audience reaction,
or whatever, but I feel totally
-- because I know a lot of my
audience is women, that's where
you can connect, especially with
young women, teenagers, right?
That's where they are.
So I found it like a very -- I
can't separate the two.  I
wouldn't want to either.
There's the good and the bad.
>> There's a little bit of a
democracy, too, in someone can
have connection to the Internet
and look at things on social
media and not have to have the
money to buy a book.
So they might like Jillian's
work or Barbara's work and they
might not be able to afford that
book or get that book, but they
can appreciate their work
through social media that
they're on anyway.
>> And we haven't figured out
how to get paid either.  Like
you don't know how to make money
from --
>> I hear ya.
>> Putting your stuff out
there.  It's not a clear road.
>> And illustration, because of
this,
it has become so incredibly
popular.  Like when I started, I
feel like it
was for nerds that wanted to
like air
brush like shiny metal and
stuff, but
it's like completely, like,
evolved to this other -- I can't
remember what I was going to
say, but...
[chuckles]
I got distracted talking about
nerds for a second.
>> Not getting paid.
>> About not getting paid.
>> Thank you from the audience,
not getting paid.
That you end up -- there's like
an economy of, like, "likes" and
stuff like that and I think that
-- one thing I heard about this
is sort of directly to women on
the Internet. I kind of feel
like sometimes you need to
present an image, and that
really values the young woman,
the woman that
is willing to sort of put her
appearance online.
And I'm always very -- when I
was sorting out, I really felt
like I tried very hard to keep
all my images -- like all images
of myself off the Internet,
because I didn't want my image
linked to my work.  I wanted my
work to just stand on its own,
and stuff like that.
And I have heard that recently
some young women feel that's not
a possibility.
You need an attached image to
it, an attached persona and
personality and, like, brand.
And I feel like is really
complicated.
>> That's fascinating.
>> Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> All right.
Turning to a slightly different
but related topic, could you
share
observations or insights about
women in
these
fields from your experiences as
teachers or being on panels or
have you benefited from
teaching?
And doing...
[chuckles]
I know two of you have taught, I
know that.
>> I have been teaching for a
long time and when I first
started -- well, I'll go back
just a little bit more and give
you a little bit of a story.
When I graduated college,
somebody said to me, oh, do you
think, you know, you want to
teach?  And I said, there's no
way I want to teach.  Why would
I want to teach?  I want to do
stuff.
And I think at that time, too,
it was... you wanted to get out
there.  You wanted to build your
portfolio, you wanted to get
more clients.  That's what you
wanted to do if you wanted to be
an illustrator, so that's what I
wanted to do too.
But over time, what I found was
that it gets a little lonely
sometimes, so you have to find
diversion, get away from the
four walls that you're in, and I
think a lot of women do have
studios in their homes for
whatever reason.
I did because I was a parent and
I had a small child and I wanted
to be able to do that and do my
work.  But I also wanted to kind
of connect
out with other people, and so
someone I
knew asked me to do a workshop
on putting -- and this is when I
was actually doing graphic
design as well.
To show how to make
comprehensive -- these are put
together -- this is pre-digital
world, for anybody that is under
30, pre-digital world, where if
you were going to do a design,
you put it together, you mocked
it up to show your client what
it was going to look like, and
so I did this workshop and I
was, like, really charged up
over this idea that I had stuff
that I had done and I could put
that together in an organized
way and I could transmit it to a
bunch of students that were
eager to
get that information, and it
made me feel like I had this
other value beyond what I was
generating.  So I'm building my
career, right?
But I'm also able to push back
some things, push back some
value to others.  And so that
kind of got me hooked on doing
it, and then over the years I
was
picking up part-time work just
as a dimension to my studio
work.
And then in 2000 I was recruited
to
lead the undergraduate at MICA
in illustration.
I had a really vital studio
business.
It was something that I really
had to think long and hard
about, but I felt like there
were some -- it was a challenge.
It was a good challenge for me.
So I did that for 10 years and
started a master's program and
we're in year eight.  I think
it's successful.
So what do I get out of teaching
is I
get to get out of my house and
my studio.
But beyond that, it's the same
exchange.  It's that same
bringing value to other people's
lives, sharing things that I do
and that I love that are
meaningful to me, and to raise
up people that are interested in
learning.
I think there's nothing better
than this relationship of you
giving something to someone
else, them valuing it, and then
doing something with that.  And
that to me, that's what teaching
is.
>> You can see what's cool...
[ Laughter ]
>> I don't teach right now, but
I
taught for a long time in New
York and you would see stuff
percolating in them and then it
would be like in the broader
culture, like, two years later
or something like that, because
they're cool art students.
But, yeah, I don't teach now,
all the same.
I mean, it's incredibly
gratifying to
see them grow as people, such a
formative time, they're like
little babies when they start
and by the end they're like
adults and it's really a
privilege to help somebody on
that.
I did feel like in the end it
can get tricky because it's --
especially New
York art schools are very
expensive and then this realm of
student loans and it becomes
this very incredibly rarefied
experience.
So that -- we haven't talked
about intersectionality a lot in
this discussion, but that
becomes a lot of it
too, with accessibility, and
that was, like...
that's a changing thing that --
the process or the time that I
was teaching I saw more and more
of that stratification.
>> That's a very good point.
Yeah.  That's great.
>> I did -- I was able to do
some workshops.  When you said
that, yeah, I did do that.
And it was the Queens Library.
I was very popular in February
and March.
[ Laughter ]
I would get calls, say we have a
black cartoonist coming in, a
woman cartoonist coming in, and
all the time it would be young
kids that would come.  I
shouldn't say that, because
sometimes there were older
people, you
know, retired people who wanted
to sit among the
eight-year-olds, because they
also wanted to have this fun
little cartooning class.
And it was really basic, you
know, how you can make faces out
of shapes and, you know, really,
really basic.
And then I would give them all
like a
line, just a little sentence and
have them create a script to go
along with it.
They came up with some really
crazy and incredible things,
these little kids.  So I think
what I got from it was also
being able to encourage these
little ones and also you
recognize that you can learn
from everybody, you know.  It
doesn't matter who it is.  You
know, it could be the older
gentleman who is a little
embarrassed to
be sitting there with all these
kids, makes a comment about, you
know, I think... and I'm like,
that's a good point.  You really
can learn from everyone.  So I
think that's what I get out of
I.
>> Great. Wonderful. Thank
you.
All right.
Here is another sort of general
question.
How or why does surveying work
by
women illustrators and
cartoonists matter?
Do you think a sense of shared
history
in these fields can help
motivate and inspire established
and rising artists?  Especially
women.
>> I'm going to start talking
again.
>> Okay.
>> Because I thought about
these questions and I felt that
was particularly a good one
because that's kind of what we
do.
You know, it's like as
illustrators, as cartoonists, as
artists, as singers,
whatever we do, we are kind of
-- you observe what is going on,
you interpret it and then you
record it, you know, and that's
-- I got that from my dad.
That's a good point, Dad.
That's what we do.  And in a
certain sense we are recording
history.
So for folks down the line who
come
back and look at what we've done
-- because all of our work is
informed by
our experiences, and so you have
a way of putting down what was
happening
during this time, and I was
fortunate
enough to have my first book --
have the
Davis do the foreward for my
book and one of the things they
mentioned is my strip should go
in a time capsule and years from
now folks can open it up and
get a real understanding of what
the experience of being a black
woman in America was.  I was
like, wow, that's heavy.  And,
you know, it's like it really is
kind of -- it's good and it's
true.
So it's being able to take a
look at what is going on and
being able to understand that
this is the -- everybody
who expresses themselves or from
their
experiences, and it's a very
important to keep track of and
get a chance to
look at it and understand,
because that will inform later
generations with their lives,
you know?  What our experiences
have been.
>> I think, like, history is
not like what happens, like how
it's told, or something like
that.  I'm sure there's a more
elegant way of saying that, but,
I mean, there's a
reason why we it is the way it
is and it looks the way it does,
and that's conscious and
unconscious how it's shaped.
So I think, like, you need to,
like, aggressively reach it as
much as I can't
wait for the day that, like,
it's -- it
feels like embedded and
ingrained in it, in a more
natural way.  I think you have
to actually put
effort into it and, like... and
be more intentional, you know,
and aware.  And I think people
are demanding that
and people see that now and the
consciousness has, like, a
rhythm, like grown so much in
the last five years or something
like that.
Even just like the younger
students and younger creators
are so much -- they see it as a
whole now and they see the way
it all works in a way that I was
completely naïve to when I
started.  So there's a lot more
questioning of those structures.
And I think it's very powerful.
Like I have to remember being
younger
and, like, I -- looking around
myself
and seeing, like, a mix, but
identify as Asian-American, and
you're looking around constantly
you know what I mean?  And
you're looking for evidence of
yourself and your self-reflected
back and it's very powerful when
you find that, especially when
you're a young person.  So I'm
aware of that too.  Sometimes
that is more intentional effort,
if that's what it results in,
then, you know...
>> I completely agree with
that.  There's been a great
turnaround in more recent years.
Because if you look at what
women were doing at the
beginning of the 20th Century
and the type of work they were
doing, they were stratified into
women's
subjects, whatever those might
be, and
that they were reflecting out
the magazines, the magazines
were emerging, magazines that
were coming out for women
were reflecting a kind of life
that was supposed to happen,
this ideal life of what a woman
should be doing and how she
should be a home maker or a good
mother and whatnot.
And think those reflections,
those images that are made are
reflecting out to not just women
but to the world what
is expected, and if that's
changing, if that's different,
and it's reflecting out these
different ideas and different
ways of living and thinking and
being, that can change society.
>> Thank you.
This really, I think, leads well
into my next question, which
is...
Women have made contributions to
these art forms that men
probably would not have.  In
fact, probably definitely would
not have.
Can you imagine a male
counterpart creating some of the
work that you and other female
artists have made?
Again, give a few examples.
Just briefly, you know, describe
or mention...
>> Margine Setropy wrote about
her experience being a woman in
the Middle East I think would
have been impossible for a man
to do.
>> Because my strip was a
collection of women, and that's
all that was in the
strip, women, and black women in
particular.  Can I imagine a man
doing what I did?  Nah...
[ Laughter ]
Nah.
As a matter of fact, my -- I was
in a bunch of papers, but I
wasn't in my New York area.
I think the closest paper may
have been the Baltimore Sun or
maybe Philadelphia or something.
But I live in book Brooklyn.
So nobody knew -- I would say
I'm a cartoonist, but nobody
knew what my strip was.  So I
would explain.  I have a strip,
a weekly strip, it's all women,
talking heads, all black women.
Oh, man! Just take another
opportunity to put the black man
down.
I'm like, wait... wait...
My point of view, just because
it's a black woman, a woman
speaking, means that it's
anti-men?
And likewise, how is being
pro-Black being anti-White in
it's not.
And if a guy were to see it --
and I got letters that they have
a problem with a
strip that I have done, my point
to guy would be -- let's see,
you probably have
more of a problem with your
mirror, and if you have trouble
with her
observations and what she has to
say, then look into yourself,
because it's her observations of
your life, and if that's -- if
you see yourself and you're
getting upset, that's not my
issue, you know.
But to see a man do specifically
what I did, that couldn't
happen.
>> That's like part of the
thing also of, like, you can't
be a whole person,
you need to be, like, woman or
Asian woman or whatever, and
like you're just supposed to,
like, exist in that sort of
static identity and not have,
like, complex feelings about
stuff.  So, yeah, I don't know.
I mean, I guess -- my work has
always
been sort of, like, even when it
started, I know I had ha lot of
female topics.
You got pigeonholed into --
she's really great -- like
that's her topic, is girls and
women, and like anytime -- I
feel like for a while, if
anything horrible happened to a
woman in the newspapers, like
some story that was horrible to
a girl, I was like, call
Jillian.  She's really good with
that kind of topic.
So it's interesting that you're
glad you can, like, present that
really empathetic point of view,
but then it's
like you can get pigeonholed.
Yeah, for sure.
>> And I think all of you show
that in your work.
I mean, really the range of
subjects
that you cover and issues, it's
-- to me that shows progress.
And did you -- I'm sorry.
>> I don't think I ever got
pigeonholed
on women's topics, per se, but I
got
pigeonholed in depressing
topics, like
depression or divorce or, you
know murder.  I was really good
at that.
But it gave me an opportunity to
put women in there, you know.
The more interesting to draw.
Women.
>> I feel like one more thing
on the race thing, too, like
sometimes it can feel like when
you're working in some of
these spaces that, like, the
pubbishers
or editors, you're a person of
color, it
can feel that you were okay,
like up to this boundary line
of, like, your experience, and
as long as you don't cross that
experience, then, like, we're
all good and we love it and we
love you, and then like -- but,
like, don't push that.
>> Don't go too far.
>> And for me -- again, it was
when
newspapers were doing well, when
I started, and all the editors
who were going to be white men
who were either going to pick up
your strip or not, and
I would get "we already have
Kathy.
"  We don't need "where I'm
coming from."
What?
But similarly, my dad, 30 years
before, had a strip "Luther.
"  They said, we already have
"we Pals."  We don't need
Luther.
But you can have Heathcliff and
Garfield.  How is that?  You
know, cats.
But you've got black
representation, a woman
represented, and that's all.
We've done our -- so we're in
goodstanding, yeah.
>> And how many dog strips...
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Okay.
We...
I think you've done a great job
answering all these questions
that I
have, and I think it's time to
open up --
>> Exactly right. We have one
small reminder.  We welcome your
questions.
So please join the conversation,
but realize that if you do ask a
question, you will automatically
become part of
the webcast, which we will place
in
YouTube and make publicly
available as possible, because
libraries are all about sharing
information widely and widely.
So, yes, we open it to the
floor.  Thank you.
There are microphones on either
side that will come around.
>> Hi, my name is Megan. I'm a
librarian here at the Library of
Congress, particularly
interested in
making sure that the Library
collects materials by women and
about women for the collection.
So I'm just wondering if you
have
anything on what librarians like
me can do to make sure that your
voices are represented or that
things that are important to you
are represented moving forward,
because I want to make sure
that those gaps that we have
previously don't exist anymore.
So if you have any thoughts on
that, I would like to hear that.
>> And I am totally in concert
with Megan on that.
>> You approve of that
question.
[ Laughter ]
>> Totally...
>> Please. Sure.
>> What would be really
interesting is
for you to maybe talk about what
the -- what the collections does
collect.  Like what is the
collection?  What does the
Library of Congress interested
in collecting?  Just prints?
Or are you interested in -- you
and I and Martha have talked
about the difficulty of digital
prints and how they are --
>> Yes.
>> How they're original but not
really original.  The original
is the digital file, and how do
you maintain digital files?
Do you keep a print in there --
I
think one of the pieces you've
got is a digital print because
it was made on a computer.
>> Yeah.
No, that is definitely an area
that we're working on right now.
I would say we're in sort of a
state of transition.
We do have a web archive that
Megan
has been very active in
building, developing, but I...
>> Sorry to interrupt.
What about semes.
>> What is a zeme?
>> A small photocopy book, like
a hand made mini comic strip.
>> Just to add to that, through
our Expo collection we are
actually working with some of
the smaller self-published
cartoonists and illustrators
working now but we are also
working to build out an
cartoonist chiewm zeme
collection which broadens the
scope not just to comics and
illustration but more literature
and criticism and other things.
So that is a work in progress.
>> I was going to say the same
thing.
I think that, like, even apart
from digital print -- the stuff
just lives on -- so much lives
online, and that's all where it
lives, you know what I mean?
And so it's tough because you
have
this -- for example, LGBTQ plus,
a lot
of content is on Tumblr, and if
they decide to shut down and not
host that stuff anymore, that
stuff is totally gone.  So I
think these digital collections
-- I know they do it with SBX
too, by
read a little what Rhizome does,
the new museum in New York,
they're like
geocities thing, I think that's
really where the grassroots of,
like, comics is, and increasing
illustration as well.  Like
Instagram is just this -- that's
where it is happening, you know
what I mean?  And I think a lot
of those people will not end up
going to be famous.  Some will
but most of them -- the vast
majority are not going to, but I
think
that is really the pulse of,
like, where people are creating
now.
And it's more accessible space
than printed published work too.
>> All right.
So a certain amount of web
crawling and acquiring digital
files, I mean,
that's something that we're
working on
and, you know, we've got the
beginnings going, good
beginnings in web comics,
especially.
>> And talking to other
illustrators, I
mean, I know some black women,
you know, cartoonists and
illustrators, and, you know,
perhaps, just talking, I talk.
But just talking to people who
are in
the field, they can get to
somebody else who is also doing
it.
>> There are also I would say
some artists working in these
fields and kind
of a hybrid way, too, and
collecting their work, it's not
always straightforward.
Political cartoonists, for
example, a
lot of them still do drawings,
add color digitally, abandon
that.
We have a couple of editorial --
or political cartoonists in the
audience here.
So, yeah, there's a lot still.
>> Even right now, especially
--
because, like, the way to make a
book, either make a printed
T-shirt or a button or whatever,
all this stuff is just -- it's
this whole different way of
being an illustrator now and
selling your stuff directly
online and do you
have to then collect objects you
know, of all these tote bags?
Like maybe... maybe that's a big
part of illustration now.
>> And on the other hand, it's
nice to have high quality
prints, archival
prints of -- they give you a
sense of a
sampling of a, you know,
up-and-coming or award-winning
illustrator now.
Other questions?
Yeah?
>> This question is for
Barbara.
Barbara, I really enjoyed your
strip when it was being
syndicated and I just wonder,
could you talk about why you
gave it up?
>> Because that stuff didn't
pay, basically, basically with a
newspaper
comic strip, the way it works is
you -- the newspapers pay the
syndicate and the syndicate
gives you a portion to get paid.
So you'll have a contract with a
syndicate that will say, if you
go below a certain number of
papers, you have --
you can say, I'm done, or we can
say, we're done.
Universal Press's credit, they
kept me on a long time when they
could have dropped me.
I think they felt a certain kind
of, you know -- they needed me.
You know, so they could say, we
have the black woman, you know.
And that's really good, because
they
needed to be able to say that,
and so... but as newspapers
started declining -- and when I
first started in, you know,
the early
'90s, universal Press sent a
letter to all the creators and
said you know, newspapers are on
the decline, and so not only --
it's the same strip that goes
out to every newspaper, but if
the circulation is larger for
newspaper, you get paid more.
So when circulations go down and
newspapers start dropping off,
then paychecks get smaller, and
then they think, oh, it's not
worth it, you know, all the work
and energy to keep this.
So it was a certain time when I
was doing the strip that I
started also doing other gigs,
you know, I've got to do other
things to keep my life going.
So I worked in other areas.
>> What did you do?
>> Many things, but it seems
like I stayed in publishing for
a lot of it.
But also I did fashion stuff.
But like I've been at Parents
magazine for 100 years now.  I
see somebody I used to work
with.
And for so long.  And I'm the
research director there.  How
did that happen?  And they don't
know I'm a cartoonist.  Oh, you
have such nice handwriting.
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Thanks.
So that's how it goes.
>> Hi, I am Denise Slaughter,
long-time
friend of Barbara's, but I
wanted to ask
all of you if today's climate,
especially -- we'll start with
the younger generation here, but
someone who is using the online
medium, and I really
think you could go back,
Barbara, and do what you do
online.  There are business
models for something like that.
My son is making money, and I
don't know what in the heck he
is doing.
[ Laughter ]
I'm off topic...
Today's climate, you know, pom
ticks and
the vitriol -- today's politics
and the
vitriol on the Internet, whether
or not on the Internet, affect
the work and the words, the
pictures that you want to draw
and what you want to say?  Does
it diminish it or does it fire
you up?
>> I think that it totally has,
and I
think that there's this -- well,
I think that it is impacted for
sure.
I think that now illustrators,
especially because you're
responding in realtime and it
feels almost like discordant to
then post a nice picture of a
flower when a school shooting
has happened, right?
So I think that because the
illustrators and cartoonists are
so much in dialogue with their
audience, it's an intimate
relationship.  In a weird way,
you're kind of -- it can be
tough because you end up being
like -- you feel like you're
entertaining for free or you're
some
sort of online buddy to, like,
30,000
people or whatever, and so --
and I think that now because a
lot of the people that have
really infused this new energy
into illustration are younger
and more political and more
diverse, I think
there is a demand to question
and comment and it doesn't exist
in a vacuum, and I think that
increasingly it feels very out
of touch if somebody thinks
their work is not connected to
the world and it doesn't respond
to the world.  And I think some
of that is the
current fashion of thinking as
well, but I don't -- I kind of
agree.  You know what I mean?
It doesn't exist in a vacuum.
And if you don't respond that
means that you're privileged
enough to not have to respond.
So, yeah.
>> Or maybe you just want to be
a little more thoughtful before
you respond.
>> Yeah.
>> That would be novel.
[chuckles]
>> We have time for one more
question.  We've got a gentleman
here.
>> Hi.
So there's some really great
hash tags trending on Twitter
right now for women
in illustration, and part of
that is a
big conversation about you know,
the kid let industries, there's
a lot of women working in that
industry and at very, very high
levels but still some inequality
in terms of the awards,
especially on the illustration
side, and I'm wondering if you
have particular thoughts about
that conversation and
make sure people know about
those hashtags, because there's
a lot of great stuff promoted.
Kidlet women and women in
illustration.
>> I have a new picture book
out, so I'm thinking about that
and running in that circle a lot
now.  Again, like I said at the
beginning,
it's fascinating because it's a
may
triarkey in some ways, but some
persistence problems exist when
power comes into it, for
example, I'm super-interested to
know that, you know,
a lot of young hot, attractive
men are perceived to get ahead
in this way.
And you're just like, that's so
disappointing.
That is just a flip of, like,
this
power thing, but again a lot of
it is tied
into any other industry, like of
"me
too" it's kid electric kid lit
is having an industry money.
It's power, influence, fame.
All these things.  And once you
put that into the mix, all those
patterns just recur.  But I
don't know.
It's -- I think that sometimes
this is a very, like, nebulous
industry.
It's like, how do you become
popular?
How do you get -- how do you get
a book deal?
How do you become book to do
speaking?  Where do you get
invited?
And it's like there's a lot of
inter-socializing.  And that's
how the industry of publishing
kind of works, and that can
favor certain types of people.
And then it all gets, like, kind
of gray zoned and there's a lot
of gray zone in a lot of
publishing.  Maybe that's
industry, but gray zone can be
frustrating because you have to
be able to navigate it to
thrive, but also to stay sane.
>> I was going to say hashtags
are great.
It's a great way to find stuff
if you're looking on the web.
Or on social media.
But in a way, it's endemic of
where we are right now
politically.
It's the spur the burgeoning way
of recognizing women in a way,
it's like a thing to do, and I
hope that we get past that, that
we survive this trend.  I don't
want to be a trend.
I want to be just part of the
whole.
And so the hashtagging is great
if you want to send to the
community, right?  Because you
can see how many other people
are using that same hashtag.
It's a way to connect in with
certain
very specific topics, whether
it's children's literature or
generally women in illustration.
They're kind of two different
things.
But I just have this great hope
for a future that doesn't need a
hashtag like that for it to be
vital.
I think the kid lit women in
particular
is a response to some of the
recent
YouTube stuff -- the #metoo
stuff.  I think it does serve as
an educational tool for people
that are starting -- I don't
know the way it works and now
they're quickly -- so maybe
that's good in that it helps
people prevent falling into
these traps
or bad situations before their
career is at that point.  So I
don't know.
>> It's terrific.
I mean, over 100 -- this sort of
is a good ending point, I think,
perhaps.
From hashtags to, you know...
over 100 years ago, Celia Boat
dreamed of a time when the
notion of women in art would
become as strange as mentioning
men in art.
So we're moving toward that.
>> How about we all agree
today, it's
been a terrific panel and we
have been privileged to hear...
[Applause]
We've been privileged to hear
from
terrific artists, terrific
illustrators, terrific
cartoonists, period.
>> Thank you.
[Applause]
>> All right. I'm going to
call on some of my
colleagues from the prints and
photograph division.  As you
head out the door in groups, if
you have time to go to the
graphic arts gallery and see
some of the original artwork,
it's a fantastic experience.
And conveniently located next to
the library's gift shop, filled
with souvenirs, but most
specifically the book Drawn to
Purpose.  Thank you for your
time today.
[Applause]